Roberta, Peter, and Phyllis were not railway children at first.
They lived with their mother and father in a large house in the city.
Then, about a week after their father went away, their mother said,...
..."I'm sorry, children, but we must leave this house."
"We are going to live in a smaller house in the country."
The next morning, the children woke up early.
"Let's get up and explore,"...
...Roberta said.
Suddenly, they heard a loud noise.
Seconds later, a train rushed past. Smoke poured out of its funnel.
"Let's walk along the side of the railway line to the station,"...
...Peter said.
When they reached the station, they saw that there were many different railway lines.
A porter came out of his room and Peter asked him politely,...
..."What are the white lines for on the piles of coal?"
"They are so we know how much coal should be there,"...
...the porter said.
"So, don't you steal any!"
The children did not stay at the station very long on this first visit.
One evening, Roberta said,...
..."Can we light a fire, Mother?"
"No, dear,"...
...Mother replied.
"It's summer and coal is expensive."
"We can't afford to have fires in summer, even though the evenings are cold."
Two days later in the evening when it was dark, Peter said,...
..."I want you to follow me."
The children filled the pram with coal and pushed it home.
They did this twice and were doing it the third time...
...when the station master jumped out from behind a truck.
"Caught you!"...
...he shouted.
"You young thief!"